his Babel's untranslatable yet he
remains undebatable true even the Dems
are hating that old Joe won't be
debating a new poll finds an 8 out of 10
dams want to see primary debates ahead
of the 2024 presidential election and
that includes 72 percent of Joe Biden's
supporters and by supporters I mean live
in nurses
but bummer for everyone because I'm
pretty sure it's not going to happen
incumbent presidents even the ones with
all their marbles simply don't debate
their primary Challengers and it's even
less likely if they're an incumbent
president who's also clinically dead
I mean they got all the power already
why chance it first rule of debating
don't give the competition a platform
while you're falling off yours
and the last thing Biden's caretakers
want is the old man making up his own
language in front of Millions on live TV
ban on transester Americans transgender
Americans let's go late and lick the
world from us up for which year for
Muslim athletes like Kareem
and and and Joan Shin Gangnam Style
oh my God koala
of Putin's kleptography yeah
kleptocracy and Club the guys who were
the kleptocracies
couldn't have said it better myself at
least not without a massive head wound
our thoughts and prayers go out to Joe's
sign language interpreter
it's Prime primary opponents aren't
happy either Afghan Jr said it's
unfortunate probably because he knows
he'd mop the floor with Joe in a debate
but then again an actual literal mop
could probably mop the floor with Joe
too I wonder what Joe's got to say
oh yeah come on I I just don't want to
debate that Kennedy guy I want to be
Marianne I like her Marianne the
professor ran Marianne I always liked
everyone like the other one it was a
good show they were Hillbillies but they
had to move from Beverly Hills it's not
a joke
but uh yeah I'll debate you Marianne
anytime you can use that list be yours I
like your little lisp and I'll use my
whisper because when I whisper he got to
get in close
and I can smell your head I bet you
smell like potpourri and patchouli oil
cat
what do you think do you think he's
going to debate anybody it kind of sucks
that he like pretty much assumes he's
got this in the bag which makes me
suspicious of a lot of things
yeah I mean of course he does uh I mean
I don't know I don't understand how the
fact that it included 70 72 percent of
the those who support Joe Biden like the
eight percent who don't support him are
like yeah go debate those people make
sense to me yes because it's never in
like this sort of format where you know
he has to think and then process
information and then respond to it he
does not he does not do that well or
even in a competent manner yeah
obviously I think that they should let
people debate I think that there should
be more than just two parties that are
invited to a debate I think that the
more information that we have the better
it is unless your attempt is to delude
that's what I do I love diluting people
Joe that's your real name what do you
what's your take on this topic this Hot
Topic I think they need to have the
debates because he coasted the last
timer yeah because of covid and because
he was hiding in the basement and to
have somebody's going to be present the
second time but no debating is
ridiculous but the person we really need
to get debating for Democrats is Kamala
because if they win she's going to be
president because there's no way this
old fart's making it through a second
term yeah so they should have the
debates look at Mary Williamson she
comes out she sages the room she gets
everybody's chakras balance
uh RFK Jr comes out he rips up
everyone's vaccination cards I was in
the air like confetti be a good time and
that's new we need to see kamla because
she's going to be the one who is is
going to be president and I think even
Cornell West I would love to see him on
a debate stage let's talk about these
ideas let's hear what people have to say
instead of just trying to push this old
fart through to another round yeah well
Walter do you think the Democrats even
care if Biden is fit
I don't believe this story at all really
yeah because if 80 percent of Democrats
want Joe Biden to debate that means they
want him to lose because if he stands up
there and opens his mouth versus RFK
he's going to lose yeah yeah
um that's not a debate uh RFK versus Joe
Biden that's a meal okay
um
so why would 80 percent of Democrats
want this obviously self-destructive
disaster to take place that means
secretly they don't support him I'm
serious yeah yeah so they want to get
him out they're hoping something else
happens yeah that can allow them to
still respectively call themselves
Democrats but not have to have this guy
be president it's like that's why uh
Gavin newsom's is hovering around there
like one of those here yeah you're kind
of mangy relatives you know you know
you're dying
they're outside they keep trying to trip
over the machine that keeps you alive
whoops unplugged it Greg yeah I'm
totally predicting this happening to me
Brooke yes
give me your Insight
uh well no I agree with you I didn't
have that Insight but it does make
perfect sense why 72 percent I think of
Democrats do want to see him debate
because they do want another Democratic
uh candidate for president
um and you know what you said in the
intro really hit home because it's such
arrogance you know debates are not
constitutionally mandated but it's a
intrinsic part of a functioning
democracy it's like you know wanting to
get a job and then not having the job
interview okay refusing to debate shows
this arrogance and entitlement that's
undemocratic and Un-American and if
anything these primaries are about
exactly that Biden's mental health and
his ability to continue to serve that's
exactly what they're for they really are
when you think about it it's like why
and so it's like we the American public
should have a right to give this thing a
test drive one more time and maybe he'll
surprise us I don't think he will but it
depends on the mix of medications they
use uh generally I mix a little upper
and a downer when I'm doing a debate but
no and but then also he has no he has no
worries about this which makes me think
that they they know something's up and
they're gonna they're they're safe I
don't know what it is but
we'll just table that for some other
time hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else